nos dicen que un suplemento de 0.4 150
gramos de potasio contiene 22 por ciento
de potasio por massa el potasio está
presente en el suplemento como cloruro
de potasio con masa molar 74 puntos 65
gramos por mol cuántos gramos de cloruro
de potasio tiene el suplemento de
potasio pausa en el vídeo y vean si
pueden resolverlo por su cuenta pero les
daré una pista es posible que necesiten
una tabla periódica de los elementos así
que aquí les muestro una muy bien vamos
a resolver esto juntos ya nos dieron la
masa molar del cloruro de potasio pero
nos va a ser útil conocer la masa molar
del potasio y vemos que es 39.10 así que
para el potasio es 39.10 esta es su masa
atómica promedio pero también podemos
verlo como 39.10 gramos por mol de
potasio podemos escribirlo así y creo
que esto es todo lo que necesitamos de
la tabla periódica de los elementos así
que como podríamos encontrar cuántos
gramos de cloruro de potasio hay en el
suplemento de potasio
lo que podemos hacer es decir muy bien
veamos cuál es la masa total del
suplemento y multiplicamos la por 22%
para calcular cuál es la masa del
potasio que tenemos vamos a calcularlo
la masa del potasio va a ser los 0.4 150
gramos por 22% que va a ser igual a
sacamos la calculadora 0.4 150 por 22%
un 0.22 es igual a 0.0 99 así que esos
son los gramos de potasio que tenemos y
ahora podemos usar esto para calcular
cuántos moles de potasio tenemos y si
sabemos cuántos moles de potasio tenemos
y todo el potasio está presente como
cloruro de potasio entonces tendremos el
mismo número de moles de cloruro de
potasio y podremos calcular esto podemos
conocer la masa del cloruro de potasio
porque nos dieron la masa molar vamos a
hacerlo tenemos 0.0 99 gramos de potasio
y queremos calcular cuántos moles de
potasio tenemos vamos a multiplicarlo
por un molde potasio cuántos gramos de
potasio tiene una masa
ver aquí que es 39 punto 10 gramos por
mol así que es 39.10 un moles
equivalente a 39 punto 10 gramos por lo
que si se trata de potasio este cálculo
nos irá los moles de potasio ahora
tenemos exactamente un átomo de potasio
por cada molécula de cloruro de potasio
así que cualquiera que sea este número
vamos a tener el mismo número de moles
de cloruro de potasio pero para dejar
esto más claro lo voy a escribir
tenemos un molde cloruro de potasio por
cada molde potasio y pueden ver cómo se
cancelan estas unidades esto cancela
esto y esto cancela a esto otro por lo
que este cálculo nos va a indicar los
moles de cloruro de potasio pero
queremos saber la masa del cloruro de
potasio así que multiplicamos esto por
la masa molar por 74.55 gramos de
cloruro de potasio por cada molde
cloruro de potasio esto se cancela con
esto y nos dice cuántos gramos de
cloruro de potasio tenemos permítanme
sacar la calculadora
si tenemos 0.99
/ / 39.10 x 1 x 74.55 va a ser igual a
esto y ahora permítanme considerar los
dígitos importantes aquí veamos de toda
la información que usamos hay 3 cifras
significativas aquí hay 3 y acá hay 4
aquí hay cuatro por lo que si
multiplicamos muchas cosas y las
dividimos tenemos que tomar el número
menor de cifras significativas así que
es tres así que redondeamos esto a tres
cifras por lo que tenemos cero puntos
189 gramos
esto es vamos a ponerlo en otro color
cero puntos 189 gramos de cloruro de
potasio que es exactamente lo que nos
piden y con esto terminamos